make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so a few months ago I had created a
series on verses characters where I
basically took two chemical characters
from Marvel and DC and I pit them
against one another to see who would win
and it really seemed to be popular with
you guys a lot of you guys really really
seem to like it but at the time my
channel was kind of going through waxes
and wanes so I had to sort of vacate at
for time but I want to bring it back but
I figure if I'm gonna do that what
better way to kick that off at least a
test the waters and see if they're still
interest in it then to do the DC versus
Marvel crossover now for those of you
guys who don't know Marvel and DC had
had crossovers for quite some time and
it really just started out with an
experiment with Superman and spider-man
but it proved to be wildly successful
and Marvel and DC did this with their
most popular characters there was a
Punisher Batman crossover so on and so
forth with the 1990s the comic industry
was on the verge of collapse just
because you had the speculator boom he
had the great you know colored bubble of
the 1990s and I've got a great big
series on that in my valiant my valiant
comics videos you guys are welcome to
check out you'll find that video down in
the description but the result was that
Marvel and DC decided to pull out all
the stops in 1995 and 1996 and basically
bring these crossovers to a head and
have a company-wide crossover and so
what this does is it splits it basically
takes the the 11 best heroes from Marvel
and from DC and it puts them against one
another to see who will win but the way
that this was done is half of the fights
were basically determined I guess six of
the fights were determined by the
publishers and the other fights were
determined by fans and so what we do as
we get into this is we initially pick up
with spider-man now something to point
out here is this spider-man is not Peter
Parker this spider-man
is actually Ben Riley now for those of
you guys who don't know Ben Riley was
the second clone of spider-man created
by The Jackal miles Warren and the idea
was to basically subvert spider-man's
legacy the original owner I guess the
first one was Kane but this all sort of
led into the Clone Saga where the
question was it's Peter Parker clone has
been Riley or is Kane the actual
spider-man yeah the actual beuter Parker
I how does this whole thing tie into
itself and actually clone saga in a lot
of ways drove people away from comics
but the result was that
you know Ben Riley had kind of become a
mainstay in Marvel Comics at the time
and so because of this while Peter
Parker had basically vacated his
position as spider-man in order to
basically raise his child alongside Mary
Jane Watson Ben Riley had taken up the
role of spider-man in his stead and
there's some distinctions here in terms
of the costumes you know so that we as
readers can tell the differences between
the two but what this story does is it
shows Ben Riley going about you know New
York and just doing his normal thing you
know where he's just patrolling the
streets so on and so forth but he
eventually comes across an alleyway
where he's pulled into a dimensional
rift and the result is that he's yanked
into Gotham City and he encounters the
Joker in this is a funny thing about
this because the Joker has met
spider-man before there was a spider-man
Batman crossover when they went against
the Joker and carnage I believe and the
result was that of course spider-man and
Batman won but for the Joker he
remembers spider-man the issue here is
that because this is not Peter Parker
Ben Reilly doesn't know who the Joker is
and so Ben Riley's really trying to
trying to gain his bearings around here
and because he doesn't know how
dangerous the Joker is he doesn't really
provoke him he's just kind of like you
know what are what's going on here who
are you that kind of thing he's really
more curious about a situation than he
has anything else and the Joker kind of
laughs things off here so the Joker
basically just bails out and gives Ben
Riley his signature card now from here
we transition to the x-men and the x-men
are basically battling you know the
juggernaut which this isn't designed to
be anything significant this is solely
just designed to show us what the x-men
were doing at the ton because the
juggernaut was really one of the most
formidable foes being the brother of
Charles Xavier it makes sense that
Marvel and DC would show us battling or
show the X been battling juggernaut but
in the midst of their conflict Cain
Marko basically vanishes he disappears
and when he re-emerged he's in
Metropolis and he comes face to face
with Superman now what it is that
happens between the two of them is not
something that we immediately see
instead we actually pick up with a new
creation a character who's named access
and now access is an interesting
scenario here because he was created in
this story he had never existed in
either Marvel or DC and we're actually
going to learn there's a little
about him then is initially given to us
but he was basically the homeless guy
who was sitting alongside this cardboard
box when bin Riley was pulled into it
and ended up in Gotham City and the
indication here from access is for some
reason these universes are starting to
you know people are crossing over
between these two realities and it seems
as though this has happened before
and it's continuing to happen even
though it shouldn't now again this is
left
very mysterious here this is left you
know very confusing to us and so what we
do is we switch over to captured America
in New York and Captain America is
basically just fighting bad guys because
again this these sections of the story
whereby we're seeing what the characters
are doing when they're being yanked in
are just designed to show us what the
characters are doing with Captain
America he's just fighting bad guys he's
just doing his own thing but again he
vanishes and so what DC and Marvel do is
instead of giving us these long drawn
explanations on what characters are
getting into at the time instead they
play it very fast and they play it very
loose in the sense that Wonder Woman is
in the midst of saving you know people's
lives while there's a bridge collapsing
and then suddenly she vanishes we pick
up with the Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner is spending
time with Betty Ross and he vanishes now
The Incredible Hulk is actually an
interesting situation here and the
reason why I say that is because this is
not savage Hulk this is actually it's
basically professor Hulk this is an
instance where by The Incredible Hulk
has the mind of Bruce Banner but does
not have his full unbridled strength now
this is something that I want you to
keep in mind because when it comes to
the Incredible Hulk
Superman conflict we're actually gonna
see things turn out an interesting way
and it's gonna be one of the reasons why
there's so much debate on the Incredible
Hulk vs. Superman idea but from here we
switch to Conner Kent
now with Superboy this is again you know
after the death and return of Superman
and so for those of you guys who don't
know about that story it was basically
DC trying to find a way to make Superman
relevant and the most logical way to do
it seemed to be to kill him off and then
bring him back but while he was gone DC
launched a story called reign of the
Superman where we got the Eradicator we
got cyborg we got John Henry iron and
steel and we got Superboy this is
basically the continuation of his story
just because he was so wildly popular
when he first showed up he was your
quintessential 1990s superhero he had
the leather jacket he had the sunglasses
the whole nine yards and fans absolutely
loved him and so because of that he
stuck around and
again just like everybody else he gets
yanked into another universe
he gets yanked into a different reality
and so we end up switching over to Lobo
in deep space and again Lobos is doing
his thing where he's just ripping stuff
up and he gets yanked as well and this
is this is basically the pattern that
happens with every single person while
the x-men are trying to figure out what
happened with que Marko while they're
trying to figure out where it was that
he was teleported to we end up seeing
that Wolverine that gambit and storm are
teleported away kyle rayner electra thor
the flash wally west Aquaman
silver surfer Shazam name of the
Submariner Quicksilver Catwoman you know
all these characters are just teleported
away and so what this does is it allows
us to basically jump forward this is
Marvel and DC effectively telling us
there are a lot of characters that have
been pulled in and so for us as the
reader we're going to find that there
are actually some characters that we
haven't seen get pulled in that have
been do have been forced to switch
realities and the first of these comes
in the form of bullseye now bullseye is
well known to be a daredevil villain he
really achieved the height of his
popularity during Frank Miller's run
when he killed Elektra but he has been
teleported to the Batcave and of course
because he's a villain the first thing
he does is he immediately takes Robin
hostage now because Robin has received
such prodigious training at the hands of
Batman Robin's easily able to counter
bullseye the problem here is that
because bull's-eyes accuracy is so
precise when Batman throws his Batarang
bullseye is able to dodge it the great
thing here though is that this is
basically an illusion this is more or
less a trick and Batman immediately goes
in for the attack and incapacitated
bull's eye now the funny thing about
this is bullseye makes a couple comments
you know one of them saying that Batman
hits harder than daredevil and this is
really the height this is really the
purpose of the DC vs. Marvel crossover
this is purely a fan driven story and
has played fast and loose and what I
mean by that is whenever you see
crossover events taking place between
publishers or you see crossover events
taking place within a single publisher
Marvel DC valiant image so on and so
forth they usually give us exposition
they give us a lot of time to absorb
everything that's going on and they
usually played in a situation to where
everything is given context explanations
are usually given to everything in order
to in order for it to make sense the
issue
here is that in the DC versus Marvel
crossover this doesn't happen and so
with you know Batman and in Tim Drake
subduing bullseye Tim Drake's
immediately teleported away and we don't
really know why but what we do know is
that he's teleported away into the bed
of Jubilee in the Marvel Universe and so
this is effectively how things work now
the second iteration of this comes in
the form of the Daily Planet and Jay
jonah Jameson now as we know Jay jonah
Jameson is he's the Daily Bugle guy and
Marvel Comics but when he appears in The
Daily Planet he basically just takes
over the position of editor-in-chief
we're not told how he does this and
we're not told why he simply just is
he's simply just the guy who's running
the show now and again this is just an
example of them playing everything fast
and loose this is just an example of
them playing everything you know without
a whole lot of exposition here and so at
this point it's basically just a
scenario of Marvel characters versus DC
characters and the question is what's
going on here we initially pick up with
with the absorbing man going against
John Henry iron steel now this is
actually a pretty formidable fight
because you know crusher creel can
basically turn his body into a material
so long as he touches it and so going
against John Henry irons going against
steel if he touches you know John Henry
irons uniform he'll make his body into
that material and so from here we jump
to how Rayner Kyle Rayner is going
against the Green Goblin Captain America
is battling Bane and of course daredevil
is going against the Riddler we also
have Batman who's dealing with venom we
have Shazam who's dealing with Doctor
Doom The Punisher dealing with
Deathstroke as well as Martian Manhunter
and firestorm going against Johnny Storm
and Ben Grimm and this is the pattern
that just keeps repeating itself and
this is why this story was so huge
because it's a dream scenario what
happens when our favorite character is
the most popular characters from Marvel
and DC basically end up fighting one
another now again a lot of answers
aren't being given here of course you
know Superman playing the role of car
Clark Kent is asking the question to you
know both himself and anybody who
happens to see the situation what's
going on does anybody have any idea
what's happening and so what we do as we
pick up with the end of this first issue
is we basically follow the spectre and
what we find out what the spectre is
that you know he alongside the Living
Tribunal in Marvel comic
are also trying to understand everything
that's going on but from their
perspectives because a living tribunal
is second in command to the one above
all to basically God and the Marvel
Universe and because the spectre is an
agent of God the judeo-christian God in
DC Comics the fact that they don't know
what's going on is a huge deal all they
really know is that things are changing
but from both of their perceptions they
also come to the realization that there
are these two godly beings that have
never been seen before and both of these
beings represent or I guess one of the
represents Marvel the other well that
represents DC and they seem to be
bridging the gap between one another in
a sense that they're responsible for the
reason for why these heroes are crossing
over with one another as so as we
continue into part two of DC versus
Marvel this is where we begin to
transition away from our discussion on
heroes and villains from the DC universe
who have been transported to Marvel and
those from Marvel who have been
transported to DC and we start getting
into battles between the most prominent
characters from both DC and Marvel but
the first thing we get here is a little
bit of explanation now I'm actually
taking this out of continuity in the
story because this is given to us later
in the story but I think that at the
beginning it's a really good place to
put this what we're told is that
unbeknownst to us as the reader at the
beginning of all things there were
basically two brothers one brother
represented the DC Universe and one
brother represented the Marvel Universe
and the result was that while they were
relatively aware of the other's
existence they simply chose to ignore
each other the problem is that because
they were two halves of a whole each one
desired to be unique and to be whole in
and of himself the only way for them to
do this or seems to you know seem to be
able to do this was to basically battle
one another and the loser would have
their universe wiped out and so that's
exactly what they've done they've
basically created kind of a battleground
using the characters of the Marvel and
the DC Universe and they've chosen to
pit them against one another and whoever
loses basically loses their reality now
one distinction to make here is that
this is not a battle to the death this
is simply an instance of proving who's
superior so all that's really necessary
is for one hero to knock out the other
in order to gain the victory so you know
Thor doesn't have to kill Shazam he just
has to overpower and knock him out and
so you're gonna see the
in the story you're not really gonna see
you know characters killing each other
you're gonna see characters knocking
each other out now the reason behind
this is something that I'm not a hundred
percent sure of because finding
interviews from writers you know from
Peter David or Ron Mars who wrote this
story uh it is difficult at best and so
there really isn't a definitive
explanation coming from either publisher
on why this decision was made but if I
had to hazard a guess I would say
because this was targeted towards kids
and you know even though the comics code
Authority wasn't really in existence
even though there weren't really rules
on the kind of content that comics could
display in terms of violence there was
still just sort of a social contract
there was just a measure of decorum
you couldn't have characters just
killing each other arbitrarily not only
that it was difficult for fans to make a
distinguished difference between what's
in continuity and was out of continuity
and so if in this story
Wolverine had died and then he showed up
in the Marvel Universe perspective
readers would have been like well what
happened why is Wolverine not dead I
thought he died in Marvel vs. DC and so
you know for that reason again I'm just
kind of speculating here I'm just sort
of spitballing with you guys in truth
your your answer is as good as mine but
after this exposition is given to us we
basically pick up with Wolverine and
Killer Croc battling one another now and
this is really just again another
situation of these characters just
fighting just just these characters
battling this is just again showing us
that Marvel and DC the the swish is
taking place is requiring these heroes
to cope with their own situations from
here we actually end up jumping to
Thanos and Thanos is again just
monitoring the fluctuations of the
universe itself now what we're told is
if Thanos is actually sort of happy
about what's happening here and the
reason why is because again this is a
point in Thanos history where he's
constantly trying to appease mistress
death and he's constantly trying to end
life as best he can in order to make
mistress death as happy as he can and so
to see the universe fluctuating presents
two scenarios one it presents the
ability for him to rise to power by
capitalizing on the confusion that
everyone's experiencing and two it
allows him to use one of these
fluctuations are for the purpose of just
destroying the universe and everybody in
it which again would go towards making
mistress death happy the problem is that
while Thanos is analyzing
this dark side shows up when a boom tube
opens up now we don't immediately find
out what happens between these two but I
will say that later on down the line the
Infinity Gauntlet gets involved which is
it's both really cool but it's a huge
letdown at the same time but from here
we jump to a Captain America and Bane
now the the Captain America and Bane
section is again just a segment of the
comic just a segment of the battle
between the two you know this is this is
designed to show us are the two of them
are simply just going at it they're
still fighting one another and that's
basically what this is it just gives us
small little highlights you know here
and there
between these two characters we switch
to I guess we switch back to Wolverine
and you know and Killer Croc going
against one another and as the two of
them are battling they're basically
being watched by Dick Grayson big
Grayson is watching this entire series
of events unfold and from his
perspective you know as as Nightwing at
this point in time watching over
blüdhaven he's just kind of like okay
this is pretty wild but you know it
seems as though even if Killer Croc is a
bad guy if this dude with adamantium
claws or I guess you know from from dick
Grayson's perspective metal claws is
tearing through you know Killer Croc and
maybe this guy is worse than Killer Croc
but what we also know is that while Dick
Grayson is watching these events unfold
that gambit is sneaking up behind him
and so from here we switch to storm and
we switch to Wonder Woman and it's
simply just the two of them encountering
each other for the first time now what
we end up doing is we actually switch
back to Captain America and Bane and
this shows us our first victory of the
story so far one interesting thing that
that happens with DC versus modeling
something that we'll see a lot is we'll
see heroes being defeated or you know
individuals attempting to beat defeat
heroes using moves that they were most
prominently known for for example with
Bane he tries to break the back of
Captain America in the same way that he
broke the back of Bruce Wayne but
there's huge differences here the
Captain America's no pushover granted
Bruce Wayne is on a pushover for Bruce
Wayne doesn't have super strength
Captain America does and this is exactly
what happens he immediately overpowers
Bane while he tries to break his back
and he simply just knocks him out when
he throws his shield and it comes back
and hits Bane
and now again this is just another
example of how Marvel and DC are playing
the story fast and loose you know we
just kind of have to assume that the the
shield was thrown
we know that Captain America recalls his
shield whenever it's thrown and that's
it that's that's all we get he just
knocked out Bane with his own shield I
know a lot of you guys would probably
want a little more in terms of
explanation or you guys would probably
want a little more in terms of well how
does this all work it's not designed to
be that way the story's designed to be
just action
it's a fan based story and so now what
happens is we switch to Bruce Wayne and
and you know at this point Batman is
basically watching you know the lizard
doc connors analyzing the skyscraper
trying to get a grip of his situation
but while this happens Dick Grayson is
taken by surprise from gambit and so the
result is that you know Bruce Wayne
basically sides with Dick Grayson and
ends up going to save him instead of
keeping an eye on Doc Connors but what
we learned is that while this is
happening while they're distracted with
what's going on you know while Bruce
Wayne is checking on Dick Grayson to
make sure he's okay
Gambon and Wolverine steal the Batmobile
and again the question we would ask his
readers is how did they get past the
defenses you know surely the Batmobile
has defenses to keep anybody from you
know eating anybody except for those
approved by Bruce Wayne from using it
but somehow he was able to take it and
he was able to use it and in the end it
doesn't matter because again this is all
just fanservice this is all just what
happens in this in the this crazy
situation so with with gambit and
Wolverine taking off you know the
question is with his vehicle being as
powerful as it is being as fast as it is
you know maybe they can get back to
Westchester maybe they can get back to
Charles Xavier and they can find out
everything that's going on
instead we basically end up switching
over to a combination of different
things what happens is we basically pick
up with Jubilee and Tim Drake talking to
one another we pick up with you know
this this explanation from access
basically telling us that this dimension
you know this this wall this barrier
that's supposed to exist between the
Marvel and DC universes is becoming
weaker and weaker and the result is that
because these brothers have noticed each
other because of the fact that these
brothers are now fighting one another
in the end it's basically collapsing
everything around them and all these
heroes are going to have to fight and
this is essentially just access you know
becoming aware of the entire
battleground that these brothers have
made for the Marvel and DC characters to
fight one another but from here we
basically switch over to Thor and Shazam
now this was actually a really
interesting scenario to me and the
reason why I say this is for those of
you guys who are not familiar with
Shazam he is a character who derives his
power from the Greek gods so to speak um
you know he's got the strength of
Hercules and and you know so on and so
forth the idea is that Thor represents
the other half of this equation Thor is
you know the son of Odin and so it's
like seeing these two European gods
battling one another based off European
mythology and there's a kind of respect
that exists between the two of them you
know they're simply not just fighting
one another arbitrarily instead because
they are so powerful they actually take
time to pray you know before they
actually engage in a conflict and so
while they're doing that we basically
switch back over to Thanos and Darkseid
in my mind these two were probably the
most anticipated battle of the entire
conflict because in the eyes of fans
Thanos and you know Darkseid are
effectively the same character in two
different variations so this is how
exists how it exists for a lot of this
conflict
you know Deadpool is basically you know
Marvel's version of Deathstroke Lobo is
more DC's version of Wolverine you know
the characters were all influenced by
each other you know they're they're
designed for different reasons but in a
lot of ways Marvel's copied DC DC's
copied Marvel and that's one of the
reasons why this series was so derisive
and why so many fans read it because
fans of characters wanted to see their
characters win and if their characters
didn't win they would get angry and
that's one of the reasons why Marvel and
DC actually allowed fans to vote on the
outcome of some of these conflicts but
instead of a initially battling one
another Thanos and Darkseid actually
take wagers on who would win you know on
who would come out on top if the two of
them were to fight each other and so
from here we switch back to two Thor and
to Shazam and the two that we're gaining
engaging in a pretty you know extreme
battle against one another a pretty
monstrous battle and with Thor and
Shazam we would expect it to be that way
just because of the fact that with his
hammer with Milner
is a force to be reckoned with but
Shazam is no pushover Shazam is
effectively as powerful as Superman
depending on the circumstances and so
it's it was really just kind of a toss
up to see who would come out on top here
the result is that while they're in the
middle of fighting at a you know at a
carnival and when the ferris wheel
collapses on to on destroy Sam he ends
up shouting the word Shazam which turns
him back into Billy Batson of living
eyes who are not familiar with Shazam he
was he was created after Superman in the
1940s but he proved to be more popular
than Superman in the 1940s and it was
actually because of a DC a lawsuit from
DC that Shazam disappeared for you know
20 years and by the time he reached you
know while he was originally called
Captain Marvel Marvel Comics already had
you know already trademarked Captain
Marvel with their own character and so
DC started calling him Shazam but
whenever it is that Billy Batson the
teenager yells the word Shazam he's
bestowed with his powers and he becomes
the superhero but there's pluses and
others there's benefits and drawbacks to
this you know the first is that if he
shouts is Shazam as Captain Marvel in
this situation he'll turn back into
Billy Batson which allows him to get out
of tight situations and this is exactly
what happens with the ferris wheel
collapsing on him he shouts Shazam he
turns back into Billy Batson and he gets
his way out the issue to this is that if
he were to shout Shazam again he would
turn back into Captain Marvel but also
mighty has to do is stop him from doing
that and so the result is Thor does this
Thor basically takes away the lee
Batson's ability to say his name again
and he's he seems to effectively be
knocked unconscious the issue here is
that his hammer
you know Thor's hammer is knocked out of
his hand and when that happens Wonder
Woman happens along and sees the hammer
and when she goes to pick it up it seems
as though she's going to be successful
in lifting the hammer for but before we
find out we switch to a conflict between
Namor and Aquaman now this is a trend
that I hope you guys are noticing Marvel
and DC are basically giving us
situations where characters who are
almost identical in nature are fighting
one another
Namor an Aquaman are basically yet you
know those they are two halves of the
same coin you know of course Namor was
actually around before Aquaman but the
fact remains that each have their own
legacies and their own histories and
their own right but they both hail from
the sea they're both kings of their own
dominions undersea and you know they're
both kings of Atlantis and so the result
is that while
two are initially going against one
another we end up switching over to to
the flash to Wally West and to
Quicksilver now this is one of those
instances where the question is asked
who's faster the flash or Quicksilver
now at this time at this point in time
in Marvel and DC Comics this was a
legitimate question because there were
instances where Quicksilver was
extremely fast wildly fast and because
they had never met because they had
never crossed over there was always this
question being raised now at this moment
right now with like DC rebirth and new
52 so on and so forth we know Barry
Allen is much faster than quick so we
know Wally West's much faster than
Quicksilver in Final Crisis Barry Allen
outran death
you know Quicksilver has never done that
this also took place before the
storyline when Wally West outran the
universe and so this was a legitimate
question back then as to which one is
faster and of course the guns are really
stuck to here in the sense that despite
Quicksilver being as fast as he is he's
simply no match for Wally West Wally
West is just way too fast in terms of
his speed and he easily dominates you
know Quicksilver he takes him over
pretty fast it's really not a huge
contest here and so what we end up doing
is we switch back to Aquaman and to
Namor the Submariner and initially the
conflict seems pretty even between the
two of them you know the conflict seems
pretty straightforward the issue here is
that Aquaman possesses an ability that
named war does not name or you know is
king of Atlantis he does have
super-strength you know he is a human
Atlantean hybrid but Aquaman has the
ability to communicate with sea life now
that's kind of where I'm gonna leave it
because I know it's a very touchy
subject when it gets to an Aquaman fans
here people say that because Aquaman
fans you know routinely say he doesn't
talk to fish you know whether or not he
talks to fishes are relevant here the
fact is that he basically communicates
however it is that he does it with an
orca whale and the Orca lands on top of
men with a Submariner and seems to
incapacitate him and so from here we
basically switch over to the end of the
comic and what the end of the comic does
is it reveals a few things the first is
that we are going to see Santos and
Darkseid fight one another but the
second and the most important thing is
Wonder Woman is successful in lifting
the hammer of four and this is a huge
deal because she's actually the first
character that we've ever seen outside
of Marvel Comics to lift Thor's hammer
something that a lot of us didn't
actually think would be that she'd be
capable of but in any event again you
know like the last video I post a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think about this one so far I'm
kind of curious and yeah this this
series is really fun the issue is you
know I'm kind of a stickler for
explanations and I'm a stickler for
exposition and you know this story is
more action than anything else and so
it's it's kind of hard to do to explain
a lot of the things that are going on
behind the scenes but so as we pick up
with part three of DC versus Marvel this
is when we start to get into the idea
that not everything is crazy battle
high-octane
instead we actually pick up with Jubilee
and Tim Drake now the funny thing about
this is when Tim Drake was teleported to
the room of Jubilee they had begun
talking with one another and Jubilee had
actually sort of fallen in love even
though it was a very very short amount
of time the O Jubilee had always tried
to find you know mr. right so to speak
despite being a teenager being a young
girl she was always a reflection of the
teenage readers who were going through
Marvel Comics at the time which is one
of the reasons why she was so popular
this was compounded with the fact that
in the cartoon show x-men the animated
series
she was us as the reader in this
universe of excellent she really you
know she reflected us you know the fans
who were running around in this reality
where things were absolutely insane but
after being teleported to a strange
warehouse of sorts both Jubilee and Tim
Drake are forced to do battle against
one another and so of course again
because this is not a battle to the
death their goal isn't to kill each
other other goal is to just defeat one
another and so this is this is basically
what happens while they're going through
Jubilees using their little fireworks as
so on and so forth but with Tim Drake
he's received such prodigious training
from Batman that he knows how to evade
individuals who do have powers and this
is what he does he starts dodging
Jubilee he basically avoids her eye
contact and he runs away and her initial
thought is somebody trying to locate him
but it's difficult to do because he
keeps hiding in the shadows
eventually she stumbles upon his cape
but when she goes to it she realizes
it's a trap in tinder he comes up behind
her throws his lasso around her and
basically and snares her and so again
this is a little bit of romance here you
know this is just a little bit of
showing us that things aren't terrible
you know that that sometimes you know
good things come out of situations like
this and so all the to share a little
bit of romantic banter between between
themselves and you know of course while
Tim droid goes to let her go we end up
transitioning to space and we pick up
with Kyle Rayner the Green Lantern and
Silver Surfer now those of you guys who
were current Green Lantern readers this
may be something that you guys will
really really really have been
anticipating because a battle between
the Green Lantern and Silver Surfer is
is on par with the incredible hold
versus of Superman which is actually a
conflict we'll see in this story neo
between Batman and black panther or
punisher or somebody like that it just
seems to make sense you know it's just
two similar characters Green Lantern's
deal with space the Silver Surfer deals
with space it'd be interesting to see
the battle between them between each
other now the one thing also take note
of here is that these two Silver Surfer
and Green Lantern have met before there
was actually a story called unholy
alliances that dealt with Hal Jordan who
is still operating under the mantle of
parallax as the main enemy and both
Holloway nerd and Silver Surfer joining
forces to defeat Hal Jordan the issue
here is what Silver Surfer says is that
the powers of these brothers who are
basically kind of screwing with reality
are well beyond even those of Galactus
and so because the Silver Surfer you
know is a Herald of Galactus and because
he's used to such incredible power the
fact that these brothers have power that
goes well beyond Galactus means that
they're not to be trifled with
and so Silver Surfer and Green Lantern a
condom in a situation from surfers
perspective anyway that they cannot
avoid this conflict and so this is
really what kyle rayner his popularity
came into play in for those of you guys
who don't know you know Hal Jordans
comics just weren't selling you know in
in really the 60s 70s 80s and early 90s
the four decades they were just not
selling and try as they might DC could
not make him popular and so what they
did is they chose to ride him out with
the story emerald Twilight and they
replaced him with Col winner a car and
it was a lot more popular because he was
an artist and he would use his Green
Lantern ring to make all kinds of crazy
things like what you're seeing here you
know Orion has a giant horse
has armor and so on and so forth neo
whereas Hal Jordan would use his wing to
make like giant hands and fists and
different things like that the result is
that the two of them you know Silver
Surfer in and Kuwait are basically
charged in one another in something
that's a little bit anti-climatic and it
results in this massive explosion and
Silver Surfer is completely unfazed or
seems to be completely unfazed and so
this is basically Marvel and DC telling
us that the solar surfer is more
powerful then Kyle Rayner now something
that I also want to address here is Kyle
Rayner the white lantern as it exists
right now if Silver Surfer were to go
against Kyle Rayner as the white Lantern
it would be no contest
so we're surfer with Holly be
obliterated but you know again this is
just another example of sort of
inspiring debate so I'm curious leave a
comment down below in terms of who you
think would win the Silver Surfer or the
white Lantern
Kyle Rayner I have a feeling a lot of
responses will be white lantern Calloway
no but what we do here is we switch over
to Selina Kyle and Electra now this is
one of the interesting situations you
know with this with a story because
these are characters who are both of
villains but they could not be any more
opposite and what I mean by that is
while you know Selina Kyle is very
formidable in terms of her fighting
abilities she's not an assassin but
Elektra is Elektra is a prodigious
assassin probably the best assassin in
the world and the result is that she's
ruthless she has no real qualms with
killing people and this is a point that
she makes - Selina Kyle you know while
the two of them are fighting one another
you know Elektra is at least originally
it seems to be bound by Selina and her
whips but Elektra Elektra turns the
tables and she basically came Selina
Kyle off the edge you know with Selina
Kyle hanging under a whip and then
Elektra says as an assassin she has her
own code of conduct she has her own
moral compass that she follows she's
only willing to kill those this she
agrees to kill but she's basically been
forced into the situation and she says
that she will not kill Selina Kyle but
she still wants to win and so the result
is that she suffers the rope Selina Kyle
collapses down you know falls into this
giant thing of sand and she basically
following conscious meaning that Elektra
is now the victor in this situation and
so because the Daily Planet you know of
course is again under the control of Jay
jonah Jameson and it exists to sell
itself is basically keeping track of
everything that's happened so far and so
what we know is that between the heroes
and the villains
Marvel and DC who've been fighting one
another so far the battle is three and
three it's deadlocked you know it's it's
completely even and we pick up with Lois
Lane and Ben Riley operating as Peter
Parker and what happens here is is
actually kind of funny you know Ben
Riley had previously rescued you know
Lois Lane from the clutches of the
Scarecrow you know and I kind of become
smitten with her you know had sort of
developed an attraction towards her and
he actually hits on her he actually
asked her you know if she wants to go
get dinner sometime and she says that
she's engaged and then of course
Superman immediately pops up you know
Clark Kent shows up and said that he you
know he's the one that she's engaged to
you and Ben Ryland just kind of takes
off you know he's extremely embarrassed
about the situation you know he's
extremely embarrassed about what it was
that happened but what we also do is we
switch back to the character of access
now I know we haven't been I haven't had
a lot of explanation on him and there's
a reason for that you know the reason is
actually want to wait into this video to
do that what we're told is that you know
access is yet another in a long line of
gatekeepers is the best way to explain
it you know in this story what Marvel in
DC establish is that there is
effectively kinda like a barrier a
dimensional wall between the model and
the DC universes and the role of you
know this kid axel who's going by the
name access and those that came before
him specifically the the homeless man
who's basically his mentor has been to
always be the gatekeepers who always
ensure that these universes never
crossed over and that's one of the
reasons why characters cross over
occasionally because sometimes you know
it would happen without access knowing
that it happened and then they would go
back to the respective universes and
that breach would be sealed the result
is that access is Arrakis access is kind
of like this this shard of both
realities merged into a singular being
which explains why he's capable of
jumping back and forth between the
Marvel and the DC universes which is
actually something that we'll see come
into play later on but in truth he's
really just a plot device you know he's
really just a way for Marvel and DC to
kind of give themselves an out when it
comes to the end of the story something
that we'll see they're in desperate need
of you know by the time it all is all
said and done but we end up switching
you know out in space then we pick up
with Wolverine and we pick up with Lobo
now one thing I also want to point out
here is that these characters are being
teleported you know Wolverines being
teleported by the brothers
the realm of Lobo he's not simply just
getting in a vehicle and taking off into
space but again because this is being
played so so fast and loose even if that
wasn't the case we would just kind of
have to accept that Wolverine is in
space right now fighting Lobo but one of
the big downsides here is that a
majority of this conflict actually takes
place off panel you know with Wolverine
having a healing factor and having
adamantium claws adamantium is the
strongest metal in existence and what
Marvel and DC seem to be saying here is
that it's the strongest metal in
existence whether it's Marvel or DC and
that's exactly what happens he basically
takes the fight of course with as
healing factor he's able to deal with
the the blows of Lobo and they start
fighting each other behind a bar and the
result is we don't see a lot of what
happens we don't really see who it is
you know I guess how Lobos defeated all
we know is that Wolverine is the person
who comes out on top smoking a cigar and
and this is is it really designed to be
a serious thing because of the fact that
Wolverine was so over-the-top and crazy
in terms of his character development DC
responded by creating Lobo who was
designed to be over-the-top and crazy
designed to be a parody basically of
Wolverine and so this is just kind of a
really designed to be a comedic thing
you know to be honest is designed to
show just two ridiculously over-the-top
characters fighting against one another
but at this point we jump back to Wonder
Woman and again in the last video we had
talked about how Wonder Woman had
discovered the hammer of Thor and she
succeeded in picking it up and when she
did it made her you know Wonder Woman
with all the powers of Thor changed her
outfit the whole nine yards but for her
because she's gonna be fighting a storm
and because Wonder Woman is a woman of
Honor
having the hammer would destroy any
chance that storm has of being
successful and so Wonder Woman actually
drops that she abandons the power of
Thor and just decides to fight you know
the storm one-on-one mano a mano the
problem with this is that despite her
vaunted strength despite her you know
her ability to fly and so on and so
forth storm controls the elements and
that's the one thing that Wonder Woman
seems powerless against and that's
exactly what happens you know
storm starts calling down the the power
of electricity and she just keeps
shocking you know Wonder Woman over and
over again but what also happens here is
storm begins to develop a respect for
Wonder Woman now it's not to say they
didn't have a respect for each other
before but with storm because
she is you know such a strong female
character it's kind of extending that
you know with Wonder Woman being from
thermosphere
because she's raised or was raised in a
society where it was it was
predominantly women and it was women
have you know those those women having a
sort of a code of honor among themselves
it extends to both storm and Wonder
Woman herself you know and so storm sees
her very much dawn is really a
biological sister but as you know a
sister on a very personal level in the
sense that they you know they form a
kind of bond here you know that they
have respect for one another and so in
the end or improves to be successful
against Wonder Woman and in in the end
you know she kind of cradles her in her
arms it apologizes for attacking her in
such a way but you know storm of course
comes out on top here and so what we do
is we switch to a Greenwich Village and
we pick up with Superboy Conner Kent and
we pick up with Ben Wylie now because of
the fact that Monell versus I guess DC
versus Marvel was a story that those who
wouldn't normally read comics when in
God for people who were getting into the
story at the time there was some
explanation on who these characters were
Conner Kent was one in particular
because a lot of fans who weren't
reading you know comics after the death
of Superman you know didn't really know
who Conner Kent was they saw him as
Superboy but they didn't know anything
beyond that and so this is what's kind
of given to us you know been Riley asked
the question you know who are you what
is it that you're capable of and you
know Conner Kent says that he's
basically a clone of Superman you know
he emerged after Superman supposedly
died and you know and even then you know
it kind of takes Ben Rawley by surprise
she's like really yeah you know clone
and it's it's kind of a funny situation
but again it's just designed to sort of
refresh those of us who wouldn't
wouldn't have known about Conner Kent
and so while the two were going against
one another because of the fact that Ben
Riley has all the same powers as
spider-man Peter Parker he's able to
easily evade you know the attacks of of
Superboy Superboy is fast he's very
powerful
but Ben Riley has the proportional
strength of a spider and so the result
is that while the match seems even
between the two ones of happening here
is Ben Riley basically outwits
Conner Kent he stands in front of an
electrical generator and when Conner
Kent comes charging towards him Ben
Riley jumps out of the way and then
covers him in impact webbing and allows
Superboy to be electrocuted to the point
where it basically just knocks him off
and so what we do here is we switch to
downtown
list and we pick up with Professor Hulk
now again this is the Incredible Hulk
with the mind of Bruce Banner but it
costs a portion of his strength so this
is not a full-powered Incredible Hulk
and that's a very important difference
to distinguish here because in this
conflict
metallo the villain of Superman is
basically wreaking havoc in downtown
metropolis and fighting against the Hulk
and so you know what is up happening is
that while the hope is at least seems to
be taking on metallo the Superman makes
his appearance known the two of them
team up they defeat metallo but then
they're teleported away to you know the
middle of nowhere and they start
fighting against one another did Matt
the the battle actually seems extremely
even between the two and the result is
that Superman actually comes out on top
here but what he says is that it took
everything he had to take the Incredible
Hulk down now this is why I say this is
so important because if this had been
like savage pull if this had been the
Incredible Hulk from the onslaught saga
whose mind was removed from the
influence of Bruce Banner by Jean Grey
he probably would have taken Superman
out he probably would have taken him out
pretty easily to be quite frank but
because of the fact that this is
Professor Hulk because a strength has
been reduced
you know Superman still had to use
everything he had and so once you know
once professor Hulk is knocked
unconscious
the Superman basically just lies in wait
and so what we do is we switch back to
Manhattan and we pick up with Batman and
Captain America now as the two of them
are going against one another Captain
America is actually getting really
frustrated with Bruce Wayne and the
reason why is because Bruce Wayne is a
prodigious fighter when it comes to you
know hand-to-hand combat as well as
using his surroundings and in fact the
Bruce Wayne's ability to meld into the
shadows is really his strong suit here
and this is what happens Captain America
is great when it comes to fighting a foe
he can see he's terrible when it comes
to fighting a foe he cannot see and
Bruce Wayne picks that up and begins
using it to his advantage he the problem
with this is that because the two are so
evenly matched
Captain America comes to the conclusion
that one they've been fighting for hours
and two that would probably end up
fighting for days and so what he says is
that their efforts are probably better
suited in finding a way to stop the
brothers from screwing with reality as
opposed to fighting themselves but in
the midst of you know this conversation
between the two of them the sewer system
is flooded with water
while Captain America does try to throw
his shield - you know incapacitate that
man and he ends up missing but Batman
ends up hitting Captain America with one
of his batteries and so you know Steve
Rogers is immersed in this water and
seems to be drowning and so while Batman
does make it to the top you know he
swims back down he grabs Steve Rogers
and he brings it back to the surface the
problem here is that because Steve
Rogers was unconscious even if only for
a moment he you know Batman was
basically declared the victor but what
is up happening is that as they emerge
from the sewer system they're greeted by
access and his mentor and this is
basically where access provides an
explanation he simply says that he is a
character who represents a gateway
between these realities he represents a
way for you know Batman and Captain
America to figure out our guest gain a
better understanding of what's going on
with these brothers but what isn't
happening is that while they are in the
middle of this conversation the two
brothers join hands with one another and
the two brothers stop existing as
individuals and they emerge as a
singular entity and what this did is an
allowed Marvel to go forward I guess now
Marvel and DC to go forward creating
something called the amalgam universe
now with that being said uh we're gonna
bring this video to an end and we'll
actually pick up with what the amount of
em universe is because in the next video
we'll run over it but I'm not gonna go
super in-depth into it just because you
know the Onaga universe was actually
pretty huge there was a lot to it
so as we pick up with part four of the
DC vs. Marvel event we start out now
with a quick explanation on the amalgam
universe so because DC vs. Marvel was
selling like gangbusters when it came
out the both companies had the idea to
basically create a self-contained
universe and that's what happened at the
end of the last video you know when the
when the brothers merged with one
another and they created the amalgam
universe what Marvel in DC did is they
went back and they started creating
origins and they treated these
characters as if they'd existed all
along and so you know for example dark
claw is you know Logan Wayne it's a
combination of Batman and Wolverine and
they provided an origin for his
character you know they they did this
with every single amalgam member the
issue
here was that it was it was weird to say
the least and so almost immediately
after this amalgam universe forms ah it
gives us the opportunity to sort of go
back and to catch up on you know these
different variations of characters and
so on but the spectre and the Living
Tribunal both of the you know
second-in-command to their respective
God so to speak and in the Marvel and
the DC Universe
end up merging with one another and they
were not really merging but they end up
working with one another and they
commune with access and access uses his
shard or uses his powers to more or less
cleave the amalgam universe in half and
set everything back to normal and so
this is we're not really back in all
this with all the characters back to the
way they were before and so instead of
having you know spider boy instead of
having Ben Reilly and Superboy Connor
can merge into a singular being instead
of having you know dr. strange and dr.
fate emerged you know merged into a
singular being we instead get them back
to their normal selves and this is
really where the story begins to go off
the rails and what I mean by that is if
it wasn't crazy before it gets crazy now
and it's just one of those instances
where Marvel and DC kind of wrote
themselves and do a whole you know with
Batman and Captain America and access
working alongside one another and an
attempt to bring these brothers down
we're just kind of given like a mishmash
of nonsensical things we have you know a
Superman and we have we have the
Incredible Hulk you know who go against
the Malloys and Mole Man they're
basically working together it's
essentially the superhero is trying to
deal with their own respective villains
and set everything back to rights but
it's also a living tribunal and it's
also the specter doing what they can as
well but in the end because the power of
these brothers are so extreme they're
basically sort of left without any way
to combat the situation and so the
result is Marvel and DC they kind of
handle it on their own and they pit you
know the brothers against one another
the argument here is that because the
brothers are so wildly powerful there
are the only ones that can end the
conflict and so once they start fighting
each other you know in the midst of this
battle they actually look into the past
of both Captain America and Batman and
when they realize why it was that they
became heroes when they realized that
Bruce Wayne became a hero because his
parents were murdered when they realized
that
that America became a hero to save the
world from the greatest threat you know
from from the Nazis
the brothers this is then at best
the brothers are inspired by their
reason for becoming heroes and realized
that fighting among themselves is
pointless that they're best suited to
basically work together they they
achieve a kind of inner peace and so
what they end up doing is is they
effectively just you know they shake
hands
you know they congratulate each other on
on their own in achievements basically
saying yes you know the Marvel brother
has done some great things and the DC
brothers done some great things they
basically call it a day and everybody
goes back to their own respective
realities and in the end access just
kind of goes back into the unknown the
ending is the enemy of this is is a
perfect example of anticlimactic it is
not very good and this is one of the
most this is one of the things that
people are so disappointed about when it
comes to the mall you know the DC versus
Marvel crossover is it was a really cool
matchup until the end because I felt
like Marvel and DC didn't know how to in
this story they didn't know how to set
things back to rights but one thing I
also want to point out here is that in a
previous video something you guys have
mentioned I had said the Infinity
Gauntlet coming to play with with Thanos
and Darkseid oh that's actually in the
jla/avengers crossover which I was I was
so caught up in you know the in our
story up to this point that I actually
totally forgot about that so as we
continue with our discussions on Marvel
vs. DC or at least dipping our toe into
the waters of this what I want to do
here is I want to cover the jla/avengers
crossover event and this is the story
where Superman lifts the hammer of Thor
and has Captain America's shield and it
looks amazing but the backstory or the
basis behind the events that lead to the
Avengers and the Justice League meeting
one another are basically explained over
the course of the over the course of the
series in terms of prologues and so just
for the sake of simple continuity I'm
gonna provide the basis behind this
entire event up front and then allow us
to just go through the events after that
now something I also want to point out
here is that this story treats the model
versus DC crossovers as if they never
existed basically this is a stand
story where the model versus DC
crossovers Superman and our spider-man
Batman The Incredible Hulk so on and so
forth where all those led up to the
Marvel vs. DC event that we previously
covered this is completely standalone
and so you don't need to know anything
about the previous model versus DC
events it's good because you don't need
to know anything but it's also bad
because if you're a stickler for
continuity this is gonna absolutely
throw you for a loop
but getting into the basis behind all
this we initially pick up with a planet
called Paula MacOS I think it is but
this point is not wildly important what
we know is this planet seems to be a
combination of technological advancement
but at the same time it houses a very
simple society in terms of their
government in terms of the ruling class
but almost immediately after we're
exposed to this society a set of prying
eyes appear in the atmosphere and the
planet is completely and totally
annihilated now the reason why this
happens or at least what we're told in
terms of the reason why this happens is
because Crona has been traveling the
multiverse in search of finding the
origin of all things now for those of
you guys who don't know Crona has a long
running history in DC Comics explicitly
with the Green Lantern Corps really with
the Green Lantern mythos in and of
itself within DC Comics Crona was
considered to have been the person that
led to the creation of the antimatter
universe to the anti-monitor itself at
least that was before geoff johns
darkside war Geoff Johns Darkseid war
changed all that it really just
retconned you know all those things but
the fact remains here that you know
according to the old continuity before
Darkseid war Corona wanted to witness
the beginning of all creation and he did
he used the machine to go back in time
and see the beginning of all things the
result was that it basically created
evil it created the antimatter universe
and it created the anti-monitor and so
because of Cronus actions there was now
evil in the universe which led to the
guardians of the universe turning around
and creating the Manhunters and
eventually the Green Lantern Corps
now what this story does is it basically
makes the case that after his banishment
Crona had taken to you know beyond the
multiverse in and of itself into the
omniverse and began looking at
everything and eventually it led him
into
the Marvel Universe now upon his arrival
in the Marvel Universe he was met with
the Grandmaster now for those of you
guys who don't know who were new to
Marvel Comics because you haven't really
seen much of the Grandmaster an all-new
all-different marvel Grandmaster is a
character of course we'll be seeing in
guardians of the galaxy too but he's a
guy one of the elders of the universe
that is to say he's one of the oldest
people in the universe and his claim to
fame is gains what he really likes to do
is play games out of whatever he can
games that test the mind games that test
the physical body if he can turn a
situation into a game that can be played
then he will do that and so when Crona
basically appears you know in this
universe and grandmaster recognizes him
or at least is is drawn to his attention
Crona immediately says that his goal
here is to learn the secrets of all
creation and while grandmaster initially
refuses to offer him the way to find the
creation of all things instead he says
we'll make a game out of it and so what
happens is the two of them go about
effectively release a grandmaster goes
about effectively turning this entire
situation on providing Crona with the
answers to the creation of all things
into a game that involves both the
Justice League and the Avengers now what
this does is allow us to actually pick
up with this event and what we learned
is that initially picking up with the
Justice League that there their
existence their universe is much like we
would expect it to be and this is really
just curb music showing us how things
exist in this reality you know in the
and the DC universe the Justice League
or fighting giant monsters you know
finding some a giant machine but what's
interesting about this is that this is
not something that they're used to they
don't recognize it as a kind of villain
they would normally fight and the reason
why is because they're worn by the
specter Hal Jordan that there are
various villains or various characters
from other universes from the mobile
universe that are crossing over into
their reality now decide track here for
a second for those of you guys who are
not familiar with the whole house word
inspector element what happened was when
Hal Jordan was basically removed from
the DC landscape during Emerald Twilight
the issue was that DC still wanted to
bring him back if they wanted to use him
and so what they did is they rolled him
over into being the hand of vengeance of
God being the specter and it was
basically just a way to keep him on the
back burner for them to bring him back
like Geoff Johns did with Green Lantern
rebirth if they ever decided to use him
again in the future which of course we
know is something they chose to do but
with the specter appearing here
what he basically says is that all these
different individuals crossing over come
from another universe although he
doesn't explicitly to the Justice League
what this is in addition to this we
switch over to the Marvel Universe in
New York City and we pick up with the
Avengers
facing off against a villain named star
oh now in truth this is really just curb
music you know hailing back to the
original Justice League story what I
mean here is that when the Justice
League first appeared in DC Comics they
literally went against a villain named
star it was a giant starfish and it had
the ability to create smaller starfish
that would take over the minds of
whoever those flower fish attacked and
that's what happens here these little
starfish are taking over the minds of
you know all these different superheroes
and so on but the vision being an
Android being able to analyze situations
using his cybernetic components comes to
the realization that these small little
starfish all basically share a hive mind
with a larger starfish controlling them
with star Rho determining what it is a
candy can't do and so what he does is he
comes to the realization that if they
effectively overload these starfish they
can in turn overload star oh and send
him running and that's exactly what
happens they allow one of these starfish
to be attached to the mind of Wanda
Maximoff and in response she sends out a
backlash a psychic energy that sends
star oh just running for the hills due
to the fact that the energy is so
extreme really more so than sorrow can
handle and so what happens is the
Avengers travel back to Avengers mansion
and they get they get word from from a
character quasar from Wendel Vaughn now
quasars kind of a weird situation in the
realm of Marvel right you know he's this
guy that basically just exists to try to
protect the universe but he's one of a
multitude of people that play this
different role you know of course we
know that Nova and the Nova Corps exist
to protect the universe we know that you
know to a degree Captain universe does
the same thing but Captain universe only
manifests in times of extreme need so
Wendel Vaughn and his quantum bands are
basically kind of the protector here but
the fact remains that wendell bond also
monitors everything in the universe and
what he says is that there are various
entities crossing over from other
realities and their actions are why this
is happening doesn't seem to make sense
now we know that these are DC characters
that lobo basically just shows up and
the Shiar empire and immediately starts
wreaking havoc that all these things are
rooted in the idea of the DC universe
crossing over with
Marvel Universe and the Marvel Universe
crossing over the DC Universe now again
these superheroes don't know this all
they know is that unrecognized
characters are crossing over from other
realities and they're trying to figure
out why not from here we transition over
to Wally West because again this point
and the Flash's publication history is
after the death of Barry Allen during
crisis on Infinite Earths with Wally
West taking over his role as the flash
now with Wally West running on a mission
you know for the Justice League as he's
trying to communicate with him he
suddenly crosses the dimensional
barriers now what he's done is he's
across the dimensional barriers into the
Marvel Universe and he picks up with a
mutant that's being run off by various
humans now this is a huge shock for
Wally West and the reason why is because
people aren't usually shunned for their
physical appearance in the DC Universe
the only real exception of that that I
can think of off the top of my head is
like Doom Patrol or something like that
but for the most part there doesn't
really seem to be an analog in the DC
Universe to the Warlocks of the Marvel
Universe I could be wrong about this and
if I am feel free to correct me down in
the description but I feel fairly
certain that that's the case but the
fact remains here that because this
particular mutant is being set upon by
these humans in such an extreme degree
that Wally West's idea is to get him out
of there the problem with this is that
because Wally West is not in the DC
Universe he can't access a Speed Force
in the same capacity and this is
something that's really important here
because what curb music says is that
whenever it is or at least what he
establishes on this point is that
whenever a speedster leaves their
universe their connection to the Speed
Force or their ability to use their
speed just doesn't suddenly stop it's
not gone all of a sudden instead the
Speed Force is much like a battery in
the sense that it routinely keeps them
charged but when that connection goes
away just like a battery that's being
used the charge will begin to dissipate
and that's what happens with Wally West
the charge of the Speed Force begins to
go away and the problem is that while he
does try to make his way back he is
successfully able to do so with the help
of the Justice League who effectively
seem to teleport in there now we're not
given a real explanation as to how all
we know is that he's simply just there
this is one of the issues that comes
into play when it when it involves the
Avengers versus Justice League crossover
a bit in the sense that you know we're
basically told that the Justice League
saw that there was a dimensional rift
they saw Wally West was in it and they
pulled him out and that's it no we're
not really given any explanation
as to why but the fact remains here that
you know for Wally West
you know while he is trying to explain
to the Justice League what it is that
had happened suddenly The Watcher
appears now we could go into a huge
explanation about The Watcher the good
thing about this is that we don't have
to instead curb music immediately
introduces the Grandmaster to the
Justice League and the Grandmaster
explains who the watcher is and what he
tells them is that the watcher just
watches things the Watchers immensely
powerful that he could probably wipe out
the Justice League if he chose to or the
factory main to the watcher doesn't act
The Watcher just chronicles events that
take place and that's it that's really
all he does not only that because the
Grandmaster is able to make his way into
the JLA Watchtower the Justice League is
almost immediately skeptical of his
appearance they don't know who he is
they don't know why he's here and while
Jon Jones can't seem to read his mind
Kyle Rayner the Green Lantern is able to
use as Lantern ring to create a box that
the Grandmaster can't get out of and so
while they initially begin to question
him the Grandmaster is kind of hesitant
here he likes to play games
he sort of messes around with him and so
Wonder Woman he uses her lasso of truth
this is other a cool concept this is
another really cool idea because what
curb music says is that the lasso of
truth does not seem to be bound by
dimensional barriers the lasso of truth
works regardless of who's ensnared
inside of it whether they're from the
native reality that that Wonder Woman
happens to be in or a different reality
it's all the same thing but what what
Grandmaster says is that the barriers
between the Marvel and DC Universe have
effectively become weakened and because
of that there are 12 items 6 items from
Marvel and 6 from DC that have crossed
over into the other reality and so six
items from the model universe have
crossed over into the DC Universe and
six items for the DC Universe have
crossed over into the Marvel Universe
and so what Grandmaster says is that
these items that belong to the Justice
League the the Bell the wheel and the
jar Medusa's mask the spear of destiny
the Green Lantern power battery and so
on are currently in the Marvel Universe
and the Justice League has to go and
retrieve them now the reason why Kurt
Busiek did this is because the most
powerful artifacts are these six
artifacts now in DC Comics the Bell the
wheel in the jar belonged to these three
brothers of sorts who ruled the universe
for something like three billion years
and they were wildly
powerful but they were eventually
banished out however whoever it is that
is able to to attain the Bell the wheel
in the jar can summon these three
brothers back and used them to do their
bidding at the same time the Green
Lantern power battery allows the wielder
of ring Lantern ring to harness those
energies for a multitude of different
effects now while this does not mean
that a person can just pick up a Green
Lantern ring and use this what it does
mean is that within the DC universe the
Green Lantern power battery is one of
the most powerful artifacts in existence
now something to keep in mind is this is
long before the arrival of you know the
Red Lantern Corps and the Sinestro Corps
and all those different cores at this
point in DC's continuity you have
Sinestro with it with a yellow Lantern
ring and then you just have the Green
Lantern's there's nothing else going on
here and so what happens is Grand Master
says in order to solidify in order to
fix this problem you have to travel to
the Marvel Universe you have to attain
those items and you have to bring them
back the issue with this is that Wally
West recognizes that his Speed Force
doesn't work in the Marvel Universe and
so because of this he elects to stay
behind in response the atom Ray Palmer
takes his place and travels with the
Justice League now what what Wally West
does is he moves at such a rapid pace
that he allows the Justice League -
basically vibrate through these
dimensional barriers and they land in
the Marvel Universe now while this
happens they basically land on the moon
and the Avengers pick up what it is
that's going on and so what the Avengers
do is they travel to the moon to
investigate the source of this energy
signature they don't recognize but while
they're traveling there the Justice
League is being brought to earth under
the protection of Kyle Rayner not only
that because of the fact that Martian
Manhunter has telepathy because of the
fact that they don't really know much
about the planet that they're dealing
with they ultimately have Martian
Manhunter uses telepathy to bind them
all mentally so they can basically read
each other's thoughts and know
everything that's going on now when they
initially arrive in the Marvel Universe
they end up in an island off the sea of
och och Kaka Tosk
I think it is a cost I'm not really sure
how to pronounce that which is actual
it's a real location but the fact
remains here that when they arrive
they're met by all manner of beasts and
monsters and different things like that
and for the Justice League this isn't a
real problem
Justice leaguer easily able to take
these monsters out but the reason why
they've arrived in this location is
because within this area lies the
ultimate nullifier now the ultimate
nullifier is somebody that the Justice
League does is not aware of but John
Jones begins to analyze it and comes to
the realization that the ultimate
nullifier allows its wielder to wipe out
anything in existence up to and
including the entirety of the universe
and so for them this is an insanely
powerful artifact and its power is
actually overwhelming however almost
immediately after they lay their hands
on it
hawkeye of the Avengers shoots an arrow
and takes the take co2 Enola fire away
however Wonder Woman's able to move fast
enough to capture the arrow after which
the Justice League initially move in on
the Avengers within the Avengers
suddenly teleport away and so what
happens is that while the while the the
Avengers are trying to figure out what's
going on while they basically take off
with the ultimate nullifier there's
suddenly met by the arrival of Metron
now in the DC Universe those you guys
who don't know
Metron is akin to the watcher but
instead of you know all the dollars that
he that he witnesses or all the
offensive he witnesses being stored in
his eyes like they are with The Watcher
in the Marvel Universe instead it's all
stored in his chair but Metron has
basically seen the collapse and rebirth
of universes and he's seen all these
events take place and so he's
essentially the keeper of all knowledge
in the DC Universe and he appears to the
Avengers and says the exact same thing
doesn't really say the exact same thing
but he basically makes the case to to
the Avengers regarding what the Justice
League are what they're about and what
he says is much like the Grandmaster
that's six of their most powerful
artifacts have been transported to the
DC Universe the Infinity stones the
casket of ancient winters that these are
artifacts that they have to retrieve in
order to preserve their universe now the
difference is that instead of telling
the Avengers that the dimensional
barriers have been weakened and that
retrieving these artifacts will restore
the dimensional barriers instead Metron
offers a different story from what
grandmaster said and tells the Avengers
that if they do not retrieve these
artifacts that their universe will be
destroyed now the reason why this
matters is because Ray Palmer as the
atom had basically hitched a ride
Metatron's chair and had overheard the
entirety of the situation that Metron
seems to be telling a different story
from the grandmaster and the result of
this is that Adam is trying to figure
out exactly what's going on why two
different stories are being told to do
different people and so what happens is
the Avengers are effectively given a
boom tube and the Avengers travel back
to the DC Universe alongside with the
Justice League themselves who have
already arrived now this is where things
get really interesting because when the
Justice League was originally in the
Marvel Universe they were disappointed
by the fact that the earth in the Marvel
Universe was absolutely devastated that
you know for the most part the
superheroes had done nothing to make the
earth better but when the Avengers rah
arrived in the Justice League's universe
in the DC Universe they realized that
humanity idolizes their superheroes that
the Justice League is kind of considered
the savior of their own planet and so
because of this when when the Avengers
presence is detected by the Justice
League the two of them basically engage
in a massive battle now again this is
really just a scenario whereby Kurt
Busiek is giving us what we want to see
we just love to see The Avengers fly we
love to see the Avengers take on the
Justice League it was really the
question of which team is better than
the other but unlike Marvel vs. DC where
this is going to focus on the you know
just the two teams fighting one another
instead this is going to cover the
entirety of the Marvel and the DC
universes and almost every single hero
and villain they've ever faced now
picking up with Captain America and
Batman this is where things begin to
shift and the reason why is it's long
been argued who would win Batman vs
Captain America some people say that
Captain America would always win whether
or not Batman had prep time some people
will say that Batman would always win
you know regardless of whether or not he
had prep time and others say that it
would be a draw Kurt Busiek takes a
stance of it being a draw he has
basically Captain America and Batman
make the case that the two of them
continue to fight it would be a draw and
there would be no end to it because
they're so equally matched in terms of
their capabilities not only that Batman
comes to the realization of the two of
them simply just seems to be pawns in
this in this game in addition to the
Justice League themselves and the
Avengers and so the idea is for the two
of them to work together and try to
figure things out on their own now
the reason why Captain America and
Batman do this separately is because a
two-man team investigating the bases
behind this entire series of events will
draw less attention than the entirety of
the Avengers and the Justice League
working together and so what happens is
that over the course of this conflict so
to speak we learn that whenever it is
that these artifacts are located and
attained that they're whisked away and
what happens is it's more or less a
scenario where the Grand Master in Crona
are keeping score if the Avengers locate
one of their artifacts then the score is
one for the Avengers zero for the
Justice League but if a member of the
Justice League and a member of the
Avengers both locate one of their
artifacts it's one-to-one if that makes
any sense
and so the idea is that whoever it is
that discovers all of their artifacts
first effectively wins and so that would
basically learn the situation to either
crown out or Grand Master which we'll
see that come to fruition at the end of
the story but the fact remains that for
the conflict in and of itself we
basically have the Avengers and the
Justice League just fighting it out with
each other as best they can't we have
Wonder Woman taking on Hercules you have
Superman taking on Carol Danvers you
know you have all these superheroes
basically fighting one another from each
of the realities and in truth this is
really just a comic book fans best
scenario it's the best way I can put it
not only that it's actually Aquaman that
discovers the Cask of ancient winters
now for those of you guys who don't know
the Cask of agent winters is an artifact
that belongs to the frost giants for
those of you guys who are coming from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that giant
blue box that was glowing and that
seemed to be completely frozen in the
Thor movies that's the Cask of ancient
winters and what happens is if somebody
opens it it basically spills out the
infinite cold of Jotunheim that could
spread across you know realities and
themselves and essentially freeze
everything over but the fact remains
here that each time one of these
artifacts is discovered the artifacts
are whisked away by Crona or by
Grandmaster and each other side is
awarded a point and so ultimately we
transition again back to Captain America
and Batman as the two of them begin to
go through all this all this discussion
all this evidence that they're that
they've collected basically regarding
the conflicts of these various heroes
and the various I guess from various
sides and
ultimately they come to the realization
that again this game is being set up
that someone is pulling the strings
having both of these teams fight one
another not because the artifacts need
to be captured but for simple sport
simply because it seems to be
entertaining and so the result of this
is that their efforts ultimately lead
them to the location of grandmaster and
Crona and what happens when they come
across this location as they realized
that Grand Master and Crona had put them
against one another that the situation
again as we've already discussed led to
the idea that whichever side wins will
determine the fate of all things
if Crona wins then Crona will be able to
summon Galactus and essentially learn
all the secrets of Galactus and god only
knows what he would do after that
but if grandmaster wins then Crona will
basically lose access to Galactus and
will have to go about his way in
addition to this and this is something
that's actually been a big source of
contention is the Infinity Gauntlet
that's really the big question that a
lot of people have that I imagine a lot
of you guys have what happens with the
Infinity Gauntlet now this is not the
first time that we've received an answer
to this question but this is the first
time it's officially been addressed
there have been other times where it's
been alluded to there have been other
times where different different people
have made the case about it but JLA and
Avengers is the first time it was
solidified in stone
by Marvel regarding the Infinity
Gauntlet what happens here is that on
the planet of apocalypse which of course
you know as we know resides arrogance is
under the control of Darkseid the
Infinity Gauntlet falls into his grasp
and our first thought is oh my god
Darkseid has the Infinity Gauntlet he's
going to wreak havoc on everything the
problem with this is that the Infinity
Gauntlet only works in the reality that
it hails from meaning that the Infinity
gallon of earth-616 only works in the
earth-616 reality the Infinity Gauntlet
of Earth you know Rob core it only works
in the Rob core reality and so because
of the fact that the Infinity Gauntlet
has been sent to the DC Universe means
it's basically powerless feathers that
it can be used for anything now this is
also kind of a weird situation because
we would expect something that can
manipulate reality to work in any
reality but it basically offers a caveat
to an otherwise trump card within the
Marvel Comics but what we end up doing
is we end up following the Justice
League and the Avengers to the final
artifact and the final artifact
the Cosmic Cube which resides inside the
Savage Land and what this does is this
leads to one massive battle between
those superheroes who still exist here
but we also see some really really cool
moments for example Thor versus Superman
now the reason why this is so cool is
because the idea has always been assumed
that if a person cannot wield the hammer
of Thor then they cannot withstand the
hammer of Thor now there's only been one
instance that I know of where this has
been rebuked and that was when Thor
threw his hammer at juggernaut and
nothing happened with Superman this
seems to be the exact same way Thor uses
his hammer and tries to attack Superman
with it and Superman holds the hammer
back now this also raises a really
interesting question regarding its
hammer and its relation to Thor for
example if Thor were holding his hammer
could you lift Thor off the ground but
it's just weird questions like that that
exists they kind of beg the question of
is it possible you know would you
effectively be lifting the hammer by
virtue of lifting Thor and would the
worthiness Clause come into play
so while your brains are hopefully
exploding based on that question we
ultimately see the Superman actually
topples Thor and so again we have the
rest of the Avengers and the Justice
League continuing their fight against
one another now as this battle continues
to commence the Cosmic Cube ultimately
falls in the hands of Quicksilver who
races to gravel or anybody else can
either before Wally West himself and so
what happens is both Crona and Grand
Master appear here and Grand Master
makes the case that the artifact has
fallen in the hands of Quicksilver
thereby creating a stalemate meaning
that each side has effectively captured
his own artifact but in the midst of all
this Captain America throws his shield
knocks a cosmic cube out of the hand of
Quicksilver which lands in the hands of
Batman meaning the Grand Master has won
this conflict but because of this Crona
is not satisfied with the outcome and
instead he attacks the Avengers and so
when he ultimately summons Galactus he
basically says you know I want to know
the secrets of all things I want to know
the secrets of all creation now Galactus
initially says no but because of the
power that he possesses
Crona seems to be able to overpower
Galactus now while all the forces of The
Avengers and the Justice League seem to
concentrate their efforts on defeating
Crona we ultimately learned that the
entire game was a ruse by grandmaster
for the purpose of allowing him to
converge all the artifacts into himself
and in turn essentially or at least it
seems to recreate reality and so what
happens is everything really everything
seems to convene back into itself into a
singular universe and what kirby seek
does is he presents us with a scenario
where the Avengers and the Justice
League have been friends for years it's
like it's almost like that like an
amalgamation of these two universes
combined for example dr. doom had tried
to access the source and because of this
he had become merged with the source
wall we're not told what events led up
to this
we're simply told that this is the case
and the result is that the Justice
League and the Avengers celebrate with
one another over their victory they
basically party they enjoy you know
everything that's going on and they have
no reason to question each other in
addition to this they routinely travel
from one world to the other the avengers
travel to the DC Universe the DC
Universe travels to the Avengers
universe and they basically help each
other out
within you know solving their various
problems the issue with this is that in
the midst of this conflict Crona seems
to make his presence known and because
of this memories begin to flood back to
the Avengers and the Justice League
regarding their previous lives now these
are not full-on memories there's simply
just fractions of their memories they're
getting glimpses more or less into the
way their life used to be but this is
really just Kurt Busiek
giving us an out this is critic
basically saying that small things are
coming back here and there in addition
to this because of the actions of Crona
with regards to his merging these
realities into a single continuity is
essentially unraveling the fabric of all
existence and so the reality itself
starts bouncing in and out of a cup
Oriole forum and it begins to sort of
break down at the seams and things begin
to jump back and forth and things begin
to shift back and forth and so
ultimately once the Avengers and the
Justice League begin to come to once
they begin to realize how things are
supposed to be versus how things
actually are they more or less begin to
band together but something else to take
note of here is this not really until
the characters of Hal Jordan and Barry
Allen suddenly really own effort is
actually involved here and the reason
why is these various characters these
various members of the teams are shown
what their actual worlds look
like by Grandmaster which is to say he
basically gives them perspective he
shows the Justice League the sacrifices
of the DC Universe at Hal Jordan went
crazy and became a bad guy they you know
he shows the The Avengers the life of
Barry Allen when he sacrificed his life
in order to preserve the multiverse and
during crisis on Infinite Earths
likewise he shows the Justice League the
fact that vision and Scarlet Witch had
kids and those kids turned out to have
been the shards of Mephisto he shows
each each team as sacrifices the other
team made the issue with this is that a
lot of these heroes don't want to see
things go back to the way they were
instead they live in this idyllic
reality they live in this perfect
reality and they don't want to see
things shift but by virtue of Hal Jordan
who has again without any real
explanation returned to his previous
form before Emerald Twilight when he
went insane because he speaks to the
team and he basically says hey guys look
our worlds weren't perfect but they were
our worlds and we should keep them as
our worlds the team's ultimately joined
forces under the under the idea of going
forward in attacking Crona
in an effort to set things back to
rights now from here Kurt Busiek
actually wraps things up fritti fast he
makes quick work as a story in the sense
that I would imagine at this point it
seemed as though he was basically
writing himself into a hole and what I
mean here is that situations like this
could go on forever in a sense of the
Avengers and the Justice League could
basically team up or they could fight
these scenarios could unfold for god
only knows how long but because of the
fact that Barry Allen's here you know
because of the fact that Hal Jordan is
here because things simply aren't right
the idea is to basically fix all this
and give us an end to this story and so
what happens is that under the direction
of Captain America they ultimately lead
their forces to the remains of Galactus
which Crona has formed into his own
stronghold in addition to this Crona has
basically taken all these different
forms of energy and combine them into a
single source that he can then turn
around and use and converge all things
into a single Big Bang basically Candice
it down into a singularity witnessed the
destruction of the multiverse the
rebirth of a new universe and see how
everything came into existence in the
first place and so what happens is that
while all these heroes attempt to defeat
Crona this sort of convergence of all
they're villains begins to take place in
the sense that every single villain
ever existed in the history in the
publication history of the Avengers and
the Justice League begins to emerge and
begins to fight against these heroes and
so basically it's more or less Crona
creating a situation where it's a
stalemate where as long as the heroes
are distracted by the villains that
they've faced then ultimately it'll give
them a chance or it'll give him a chance
to continue the process of converging
all these different universes down into
a singularity leading to the destruction
of all things and the rebirth of a new
universe and so what happens is because
Superman is really the the core of the
superhero element right you know because
he's so capable because he's so strong
and powerful he's able to hold his own
against the various villains that he's
going against the problem with this is
that characters like molecule man are
still extremely powerful because
remember this is after the first Secret
Wars event and so molecule man has the
ability to whoop reality not only that
Superman is sort of the symbol of
superheroes and so while he is able to
lead his latest forces against you know
all these different villains in the end
it just doesn't quite seem to be enough
and so what happens and this is actually
a really really cool moment what happens
is that while Thor is momentarily
defeated or seems to be defeated while
all hope seems to be lost in the sense
of the superheroes are being wildly
overpowered Thor throws his hammer to
Superman and Superman catches it while
simultaneously wielding the shield of
Captain America which is basely it's
absolutely amazing and so what this does
is it allows can be used the hammer to
penetrate the Citadel of Crona giving
them a way in and past the villains as
well as allowing Superman to start
laying waste to the villains using the
hammer now again this is only a
temporary moment that is to say the
Superman won't be able to wield it again
and we'll actually find out why at the
end of this story but the fact remains
here that with this portal open Barry
Allen and Hawkeye effectively work
together in the sense that Barry Allen
sort of relives this instance where he
died against the anti-monitor
where he beams running around in circles
as a distraction for Crona
and when Crona turns his gaze away for
the slightest second the result is that
Hawkeye shoots an arrow laced with TNT
into the device that crona's using to
converge all these realities and
destroys it thereby allowing all these
different universes to be
and breaking away in addition to this
this also forces Hal Jordan to return to
his spectre form and he again also
assists and you know I guess operating
as the hand of God in terms of pushing
these worlds apart and keeping them from
merging into one another and so in the
fallout of all this once everything
seems to be going back to normal we pick
up with Superman trying to figure out
why he couldn't lift the hammer of Thor
again and what Thor says is that Odin
was watching or at least it seems he
seems to hint at it that Oda was
watching the events unfold and granted
Superman a momentary instance of being
able to lift the hammer now again this
is really just Kurt music giving us a
reason why he could lift it it doesn't
seem that Superman is actually worthy or
if he was worthy it was only for a
moment
the fact is he's simply not worthy of
wielding at any time he wants to and so
what this does is this again wraps up
extremely fast this is really curb music
just telling us that the tale more or
less comes to an end that these
superheroes recognize the value of each
other but we also have an instance where
by they came together fought off an
incredible foe and then the Avenger just
kind of left open with Metron and Grand
Master more or less making the case that
if it should all happen again that the
teams will come together again and
they'll fight off fight off whatever foe
they happen to go against just like they
did this time around with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and yeah it was it was kind of
interesting you know this is a really
interesting situation so because of the
fact that the krona was kind of absorbed
down into this cosmic egg and he would
give birth to a new universe allowing
him to witness you know all of creation
but it was really just sort of curb
music trying to wrap up a story where he
seemed to ride himself into a hole but
it wasn't bad I mean it wasn't the worst
thing ever he was actually kind of fun
to just see the Avengers and the Justice
League fight one another but if you guys
are interested in seeing seeing more
model versus DC content make sure you
guys drop a like when she you guys leave
me a comment and also if you guys are
new here to comics explain feel free to
hit the sub button and become part of
the robb core and yeah I will catch you
all in it peace
I want to give a shout out to Jason see
Austin s Jason s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B we have lot of Austin's and our
patreon as well as G gnosis 916 de
gnosis didn't give us a first and last
name so we kind of had to roll with it I
didn't mention your last names after you
guys didn't want me to throw them out
there but I want to say thank you to you
all by the way your rob4 rings should be
on their way for our honor guard members
of the rob corps for these special
patrons your custom rob four rings
should be on their way they're being
shipped to me after that I will have
them shipped to you stay tuned keep your
eye on patreon in your messages and you
will hear about them coming to you thank
you
[Music]